the staff is also starting here
an edition of May 29 for Brazil
I am bruno oliveira nelson born
marim and we are presenting here
directly from the google reptiles in
mountain view california
I know our our android studio
then we have a series of
a collection on big dolls android
a lot of other things like that arose
cool
so in today's issue we're going
do the following takes place I think
Let's talk a little while, I think.
there is a novelty that is also
interesting that it is only recently
interesting who does not take a look
still take a look because it is that
recently released a new version of the
developer user interface
So comfort when you go there
console that allows you to
publishing android applications has a
interface new deli we're done
to launch
so just enter the procon novel
You'll see an orange link up there.
trend destroys preview
de nico predicted it will change our
for new interface in international
much improved potato and makes it very
make it easier for you to
You keep track of what's happening.
with your application because what I want
always say that you publish a
application is easy, right?
The same hard is you do over active
having success once published is very
important that you publish the
application and then keep an eye on
see what's happening with him right?
It is not just put there and I hope it gives
sure one of the things that is very
It is important that you always keep track of
which are the statistics of use of the
application or whatever device
that is being used to access the
application which is the type of user with
the user profile
finally a successful developer always
knows very well who your users are
so if I ever ask the provider
so it gives me a characteristic one
characterization of how you are and
if I want to talk I do not know
this guy is probably not doing
An application is then always ideal.
you have this answer is to cut or
No matter how you use it, you do not have
that having this always moves
interesting news and I felt that the
people who would be good even if they have good
and it's is I think this is one of the
main criticisms recently
Let's move on to the questions of the
reader tamer is there are those of you
questions you have asked through the
elector mode on another time a right or
directly through our page on the
google developer day live
so let's start to do is respond
to questions in order of popularity
the first question he got here
it's dodo rafael had abstain from spring
following we use a record level
to record videos and we're not
satisfied with the audio quality
specially generated video recorded in
concerts where there is a lot of noise
tips to get the best out of your
audio the android is then the question is the
I have an application that
it records audio in then it's audio from
android records obviously it is
limited by the radio's characteristic
device did not explode I have one
positive number is it has a microphone
embedded here is then clearly a
built-in microphone
I mean, it's made for some
uses such as make you do
legal says is to make connections this kind of
thing but there are some environments in which
it does not perform as well as
for example in an auditorium room
health and victory has a problem with it
has the echo of feedback right when
example you are receiving the sound of
various sources at the same time
Just happens to arrive here at one
certain time and then there is another sound that is
a sound copy that arrived at no
slightly longer interval
this does that reverb effect
which decreases the audio quality is
first place this is not a norm
thing you're doing wrong or
be it is not a thing that you do not
goal is doing wrong obviously
is not only capturing the audio and
so it comes because the
hardware feature now exists
software techniques that allow you to
get this signal that is recorded and you
treat this signal for you to try
eliminate this poor quality a bit
one of the things you can do yourself
pick up this raw nacinal sign and you
do a post-processing for example the
on android has one has a casino package
android on the question, I guess I think
android
inside this package you will see that
there are a number of classes your
Letters to you make media effect
android one of the parts that I remember
There you have it.
that it has several effects that you
can create there using android audio né
one of the effects they have there if I do not
deception calls ecom cancellation is a
thing, and it serves precisely to
when you want to treat an audio that it
was recorded or captured in some
environment in which you have very much
you need to cancel the redundant echo in which
would be for example the case of a
concert
Can you do the opposite?
also wants to get the pure audio and do
sound like it's a concert hall
It's you who has to get a
audio that is heavily polluted is with
echoes and redundancy you want to remove
effects and become purer in the
so I'd recommend you take a look
in this set of classes in which
android if that's our mistake
point dot android
the media effects wait for something
so it is otherwise the exercise did not solve
problem for you would recommend trying
use some external library to see
if you can process signal I extracted
the original audio of it you treat the
audio in general so the experience that
it means that I had that of others
developers that audio accent
of the android she gives gives you a power of
processing is very reasonable
most apps think it will
being will be enough to do this
note that not all versions are ap
It's available and I forgot that it was
it just started
I know it certainly does not match roney
how do you do that i do not know if it says brad
Jackson does not remember but if you want to
can not hear this does not mean that you
can not use this does not mean that
you have to detect if the user is
using the minimum or higher version you
this feature this user is not
using a version enough for this
You do not use the child or you do or beck.
for an alternate version that you can
implement using an external note
something like this in proposal one
last warning with a year nothing what had
to lose a little quality a thing
like this
is exactly the user's communication is
very important in this case he understood
starting a new application that is
doing post processing
Well, you know perfectly well that
exactly is it good for the next question
We are monitoring the post here.
if anyone has a question to ask
live just enough you catch and say
just take the android post
developers and post it from new profiles in the
bruno's number but the original
aa gym and now it would be interesting
get this post on the screen in the
comments
but until it resolves is the second
question receipt
bruno since google asks that the
developers do not web to
specific versions of android provides
meters for this
good reminder area we have several
for this as explaining that the
chrome and calendar fact does not work
in versions prior to the ics world was
of lucas xavier aracaju bomba happens
so summarizing the question if we are
telling you to do here to
all android versions because we
does the opposite of what you are talking about and
makes the chrome available only this way
being says up, right?
the answer is we, our county in
general is not easy is for all
android versions is independent of the
ether make apps that works with my
version of android you need right?
Certainly you will not fail to launch.
an ep because it does not work in the car
hot then there are certain applications
which rely on resources that only
advanced versions android has to
chrome is the browser is the
extremely complex browser it has
a complexity that is extremely
big and he really needs
some movies that are available there
nuno only in Haiti on the scene then
depending on the case, what we do is
of course any player can do this
is you unfairly restrict the version
android when that is
absolutely necessary does not always have
that balance that has to be has to
being hit between you has a
application that works for everyone
users and you suddenly spend a lot
time with old versions that are not
your target audience is as far as the
possible we advice is always easy is
an application that works for all
android versions
from time to time it will or will not be
possible to follow if this gasoline
that including ourselves
we do not know if he in the case of
chrome at the time of the collective is what
will also dedicate you personal and that is the
next you will develop some
anything ideal starts with the version
more sporty without you
chatted as old as possible only
put with the pillar for your project
if during the project as a fischer
Let's give a very basic example if you want
make animation do the animation
view
remembering that version 1.6 had no
jury even though it's okay that you connect
nobody uses the version with three but let's
an example was only to understand how the
business
obviously make an animation the
view is not something that prevents the dream
that I had to leave
so you can do maybe you can not
fit or use a feature for the part is
available in two versions
now if it's a thing that can not be
done maybe you will have to limit
raise this barrier a little and
with the newest version and e there
unfortunately you can have some kind of
loss of people who will power
use but unfortunately this can
happen but it is by a limitation it is
specific applications have the minimum
It's best not to have no qualification
remembering this, we already talked about the dap
site
I wanted a chat this week I think
that will not power is true the attack is
one will only get what this is a camera
seems in fact depending on the cause of
resolution to this may end up being a
green pixel ne
this here is actually a machine
android but I'm not kid our brand
android it does all the functions of being
an android doll or in all
the sites be a doll, right?
specifically it stays there being a
doll and it also works as
one not from below for finding him line
I have here to get your legs out
him and he turns a pen drive
so he not only stays there being
android as it also serves to
store thing inside bag
impress all the staff of the
office with the pen drive is a robot with
also some with exactly that
Incredible and revolutionary pendrive
android then we would like to
software and today only the problem is that
we have to we are in
mountain view and
To send Brazil, I did not remember.
one thing I have some
the table is ok then it will not be
today
We're going to draw today but he's only going to be.
sent from next week
when I return to Brazil
so we can send more
enjoying the week he had thought
in raffle this robot super robot drive
we made the 1-0 that always makes a
some challenge is not the type of the last one
The defense wanted the numbers challenge
cousins ​​taking advantage of which was the
number with certain characteristics
the smallest prime number
Let's do something like this again.
he made that draw based on since
Twitter posts is not that it was good is a
way you are sure that the
lottery is really the win
unless we are controlled
of the inter in the thing that does not happen
So what are we going to do next?
The winner of this signal pendrive is
of 1 exactly the same and if that is going to be
that this winter from Brazil does not
said specifically because this now
mine is going to be the next one who first
post a comment in this passage from
regal time just looking at the passage of
real said no no in my dreams
comments on my profile neither
nuno gomes neto
We're just looking at the
comments from the original post that people
made for legal commission and is the
first you post a direct link
we want a link to the assignment of the
android design guide are depositing
at this point 1 bar design right this is the
our android design
then the first to the first post
a link there to the session that talks about
Context sentences
then the rain will continue to capture action and
in a contextual bar than the one that
that it appears when you
select one or more items it appears is
call her change of face she turns max one
bar no more graduation she turned one more
bar that is contextual that it gives you actions
to perform on those items that
are deleting an email from gmail
also in things like that but it has to be
this part of the floor hit this key
hit the specific page does not work
bet on a link there then the great
combat point
zaine speak that is at stake is the letter is
not we do not go resources equally
no recursion book exactly from
depth
I can not even speak after legal people
go look and and communicate the winner
and then next week I'll let you know
I communicate with the winner in vila do
Brazil remembering that it is only valid for
Who is in the national territory?
that's what it's worth and for
locations that are served by the
sedex service
It's the only way we can
send is ours and lex ne
if you live in a region that is not
answered by sedex, we can not
go to you that we can not
take you to your house in memphis
but I will not be able to spend a day with
evolution of technology, we do not go out
can get something like that and put
in the cloud the embassy of the night thinking
How much surprise, send it to me.
send a file biological reason was
low and it looks cool on the return of
patent to a patent is why there is
the next question we have here
of the madureira is the following is the question
from marcelo h da guerra minas gerais
the new idea of ​​oracle and ef mobile in
the link of ideas cross will be the
best
good to one of the things I like best
android is what it does not have is a
open platform so you are not
thank you to use a specific idea
you are not required to use a
specific
so you have complete freedom to
You use cordel you want you have
Why tell you as a player?
you also have complete freedom to
develop your own leg
I find it difficult to answer objectively
what better idea because the idea is
best idea is the one in which you
productive to this is a lot of taste
Guys I think I hear this one.
discussion since when I started to
to win with java ten years ago that had
the staff used gel that used netbeans
eclipse
this is very particular you adapt
better with the shortcut key of a duo
with the shortcut key of another né
There are a lot of people still talking
so send send the best interface
of movement
another fan of max so that's a lot
It is difficult for us to reach a
I suddenly like what I prefer
that Bruno prefers what you prefer
so there is not much is whoever wants to stay
the tip going from marcelo whoever you want
try for sure it was worth the hint but it's
a person known many options
people try and
but this day really better interface
we could spend hours here
arguing which is better but they do not
reached a consensus is that a
very personal and personal enjoyment
I personally like the eclipse, right?
because he's the team he does everything he
There are no comments
positive and negative on the team but
so in general it is a tool that
made me very productive in the sentence
judicial and appropriate to him
solves a lot and what is legal about
bt plugin that evolves very fast I
remember that today is already in the version
20 I do not know how much when I came in
in google it was here in version 8
he was rather rudimentary compared to him
today he means the
landfill was very very fast today in
for example when you create a
new a new android application on
eclipse
He already wanted you, for example,
tv that already has one more bar since it is
You on the TV that already has that master of
have focus then it does a lot
automatically to you and pulp you
can create a template including god
it is also very flexible, but also
staff you want to use fire three
I'm not going to give my
also the mayor is also the eclipse but
I had to years of arguing where is where
we make a cup of snow is
interesting this bag in brazil
next question that we have here
Madureira is the following is the question
about teams nelinha souza do brasil is
possible to get a team here from
own user to use the service
the goal my application makes use of places
and piaui is there is a way the user
do the quest avoiding the limit
recognizes that they use them
here is the short answer to this
is not everything is produced in every idea
behind you have a team here is
You just keep the load.
servers in a way that is
just for all the rodents, right?
without us having to make a do
a very aggressive charge on what
happens when you have a team here
it is he establishes for you a limit by
application regardless of how old
you have
it is also that limit that is free or
you can use to explore the
kite to small applications and the week
of a certain limit of the
You start to have to pay a little to
you receive it then as far as I
I know there is no crisis by design, no
there is a way for every user to sau
It's different because you have
just the ipi that is for is to be
for everyone an application independent of
how many users does it have?
also uses only your own
application is to try the executive
that they are always transparent
user make usability
so if you ask to fall for a
page does recognize of a penalty that
this can only be born a user
technician may be accustomed to the
registration page of an app store
so it's really something that the
people recommended or skipped the
holland the technical usability side
oblige the technician to give you news
deliver everything goes to the usability of
your own application actually resembles
that so the user's eyes exist
application when when the
documentation has two pages imagine if
you if you ask the user to enter
on a site to generate a key such as
applications wheel switch means nodes
it's a practical thing just if you
you may have passed this limit then
This is cool, and you and I are trying to see.
a way to monetize an application that
you are passing the limit of the limit to the
reasonable number of resources per day
exceeding this limit is a sign that
this app is doing starting
a success the same people can you can
look for a way to monetize this
live time with subscription with com
premium version app sales
until then because if you are passing
Congratulations, the application is doing
a cool success so you have some
doubt search the world forums have
documents monetization year not developing
android dot com then so maybe it is
the moment to look also for you to see
that the title is well because the
limit
no one talks enough has in the head of
limit for 39
only maybe we speak in china is not
so low is born the application is
serene if it is limited because it certainly
is going well as the grandson said 'no
You can try to exploit this to
monetize the application in some way
to cover these costs
even so, but there she would have to talk more
the application is not there I do not want
same users also in this case asks
asks for donations in this case if you have a
application that has a whole impact and it
not an app that is not commercial
you do not want to put a
commercial component and no ads on it
it's certainly because he does a service
for the user it is very valuable that the
people like exactly for example
there are many sites and applications that
are fully moved or
then the dwarf does not underestimate the
Donate power is sometimes much better.
you have an application that accepts
donations what puts advertisement depending on
application will be left over
then it means monetizing is not a
necessarily mercantilist thing
monetized capitalists and also
means you put a lapa button goes
get donations and keep your uncle
that working
Do you have any questions online we'll see
If you have any questions online
I can not access the post
here then do the following a question
I'll arrive directly at the rescue.
here is some legal participant who
want to come in and ask a question jack
jones
only in one year
only that someone talking about something can
talk there, just raise your hand and only
she's something to know that
Do you want to ask the water question?
that's a question he'll talk
Can you ask Gabriela a question, does not it hurt?
the lipstick we're talking about
the fall of the dollar here only increase so
that I am not alone I know the weight that demands
ipad just for him to stay a little this
service is that this google service is
the following it is a is a way of
you authenticate using the identity of the
google user play this through
of the goal and services then the suit is
a component of it calls google places
ice cream that applications can
access one of these children's
that he has just the authentication
per user in a way that you
can do in a consistent way
in several applications for example you
need the user only with the
google and linus account the app you
could make its own interface is
certain is no longer the user now
much more comfortable if you use a
interface you already saw had in the
device is not what it is for
this part authentication of google places
and after that you can for example
got a token gave to the end né
and mentioned who you can use for you
make calls given to some just the
google so that's what it's all about
this is not for the user to be able to
call country using a pic of your own
user will still be limited to
the use of the mode ae pierre kipré place zip
and other birds that are limited in the new
from an app application
exactly as it is a
way you can get a token by
for you to call service from the
Google
but this does not influence the counting of
already thinking of itself the identity of the
the user is making that call
for example if users make a
call to get for example things
he has on google docs drive
currently you will get it you need
authenticated knowing that I am for
friends info on google drive
flash that serves this touch but it does not
It's meant to make a metric of mine.
usage quota
You do not need some
ipi is here that is pure application now
cool
So let's move on to the next one.
ask here the next question valley
is
the lucas xavier cashew
bruno besides developing for android
developed beach but also with this
ex gold storyboard tool exists
the possibility of launching a tool
similar for android
then to the one who does not know the
Storyboard tool of choice
I do not have much experience with
apple but so I've seen people using
the storyboard the themes - war is a
tool that allows you to make your own
data layout tell my phone and it shows
for example the hierarchical relationship between
the screens with this land leads to this
That hurry back to this is
that excuse does not know
only this
Wow if we through our
specialty but giving a summary
so already risking talking
bullshit I think I'm just like
one thing that does it there is in our
what does adp mean?
tools that have evolved the most
to pass the time and with the passage of time
it has evolved a lot in relation to this
part you design visual interface on the
android we do not have one yet
The way you draw it means the
interactions and hierarchies between several
activities in your app
This is not only because the
government does not implement this is because
android this is a little more has one
bit more in depth with respect to
this issue rather the concept of
different concentration is not the concept it
It's more complex because
wants to be more flexible because you
has this exact mapping of a layout
for an activity does not remember what
make a tv and she stated her layout
she carries the royalties
at that moment android nothing prevents
given your tiger load layouts
different depending on the game or
some other factor eg tv can
decide whether it is based on some factor
some external factor
she wants to load another layout then
it would be difficult to use a tool that
compile time knows what the layout is
that will be applied to characterize
clearly out there but also there
already complicated everything you will have to
Use what you're doing.
after the wreck are being displayed
may increase between fragments of the river
kisses other things so he
remembering that this may change according to
with layout after which you should do the
higher time out threshold that meets the
phone, so that's how it looks
complicated we have
This way it's more work than
You'll make logic there yourself.
taking care of the beto shop possibly
I would have more working than you care.
logic means manually
coaches the code is and when I say
again through the code means
sometimes it gives the impression that they have
that writing 200 lines of code is not
only you
are two or three lines of code for
accelerate when this TV ends
This is ours, that's you.
It would have to be anyway I do not think
who did not want or not you would have to
expect this game in some way and it is
exactly what to have when you create a
new activity he already asks himself what
the activity that is hierarchically parent
activity that is created and means
that he is going to insert for you alone
the code that allows you to navigate
parent productivity for example when
You click the pen button then you
you have in your art a boat in
what button to pen when you click
in it the user should be taken
for activity parent that I
imagined a choice should show
some other activity there but not
android you already specify if the time in
that you creatively and automatically
code is implemented for you there in the
so the fact that it does not have a
visual diagram between activities and think
that I want to say oh I think it's a
thing that harms so much more than
Any way I think it stays with the movie.
crash on tt test
or better yet all of a sudden you that I
and you can create a tool that
Does this or the bad as you are talking about?
does not seem repetitive but one of the things
I like the android is the
open the system so if you think
that this tool will be extremely
useful for developers and you do not
Do you want to wait, do not you see?
there is nothing prevents the fall from you will
develop and launch this all of a sudden
become a very successful tool and the
eclipse is also the same as the
eclipse plugins or a tool
is an interesting question like
does any versions how does it work
for all versions of android
all these works all ours is then
this is something we always talk about
I think at least everywhere that the
we've done at least one
time ooo central android focus you
can not talk about android without talking
in diversity device in the a nodes
we do not have a mentality that has a
android device that is sure to
everybody, right?
if you remember when you released the nexus s
anybody else from the
Google said no, this is the
device that will replace all
it's a lie, no, no, no
This is the best screen size for
who likes this screen size is the
Only thing I can say then
I liked the screen for me, it's the best
Breakfast was also quite convenient
but the we have to say a variety
of devices that we have in the
android is very big you have your
two small daughters until those have gugu
would have the android is very practical my father
for example he spent money bought
1 902 but did not like the screen there too
I got a galaxy 5 that is much smaller then
to him he the fire in the head two in the eep
but that is older treatment have
less memory but liked the size
so that the executive channel that is
What's in the name of a personal battle at
sometimes it does not suit or can not be
ported to google tv not because
has
It's like you cut.
make sense a tv for example more
attractive a game of a kind of game
set of gps for example will have
behaved like this until you can
very strong and have a team gps on tv
and a battery in excuse now with that
of rochi in season after changing the psb
Does a bicycle that generates energy go
pedalando by são paulo or any
another city you go at the same time
You're feeding your tv and the TV has
gps and can use for example was
with her on tv here in places not here
It's just a matter of people having to take
he remembers bruno has a very selection
Good thing you presented together frame
Paulo in the goal of that year that a video
available online and that you
only a lot of this is how to do it
on how to charge eclectic phones
be the coach completely will speak
a lot is talking a lot did not know how
carry three bikes and yes on
how to make the user interface that
are compatible like making versions
Android
remembering that the rule to make a
application should be compatible with
all versions as much as possible né
there is sold in the history of the club and
chrome is not compatible but then the
always careful to only do your app
be compatible with the maximum number of
versions possible
even if they are not all maximum
possible then precisely this
google talk what it's about is
just about is to interface the
that are compatible with the number
possible versions of android
This is very important, it's different.
developer who is afraid of
android diversity it for example
I'm here he came here he speaks my
God, I'm going to have to write one now.
application so it does not stay active
That's when someone says to
there is a third device
that were only on TV or have a
third one that is very similar to him
but it's a little bigger a bit more
wide he already caught he panics
starts tearing her hair now
I'll have to write an application 500
a thousand times it is actually the just
like android and has been thought since
start with adversity mind it all
the entire set of tools
android already thought for this he already is
thought of in a way that you can
without much additional effort he wrote
asking you to function equally well
tablet or cell phone on a TV or in a series
of devices said holguín and if it is
well-planned well-planned code in
yourself
Maybe you do not even realize that you made a
are you cut to different devices
because you can use the whole
question of US dollar resources.
recipes in your favor
and even charge you can write and
write no cut but also no
be afraid to stay alone afraid of us
go is not done just this in code since
that is correct were tips
cool
enjoy the features of android know
to use this is very important since only
remembering that the advice we give
We'll talk soon after, do not be afraid.
lif
according to the council be afraid because
Your books start to get very
complicated to get out is certainly because
something you ride is going
good
If you or if you were training well
then it certainly has a structure
better than I went to do that but
in the worst case, so in the worst case
cases when you are doing
application for multiple versions of the
android you will have to have
some activities they will be doing
different for example large
device version changes are not
If you know what type you have a version of
your tv by brad another planet a
internal bureaucracy of another project
It's also complicated, I do not know what to do.
It's a complicated thing, right?
this is now if you have only two versions
one for example for the preview or bed and
another after more reasonable American-rj
so you may have to in the worst case have
that make a separation in two by two
for example in the era after the
nail in the field it is important not to
only a catch and if possible
keep pk only you keep all your
the issue of the history of
reviews of downloads is legal and
is forming your doctor question
gilson júnior de curitiba even more
specifics may come next, yes I
wanted to make one out with list to use
chumba and such and can not make a
specific version the hypothesis of launching
a more specific product we have
the pleasure to help also stay at
I want you guys
now you just get confused by something that
I remember that we as a goalkeeper
already gave several talks saying to
everybody does not no you have to do
a small leftovers as you are talking about
will offer to make a very precarious
best in terms of cut rate
Only I remember that recently launched
google places launched just showed
sins that sense does it then the
sense of you and you throw many
apply is the following at the time people
You're always talking, do not make a
we only make a chair and after
Throw your ninth black goal ufop coke was
our logic in this is not is not is not
it was an accident being very easy
to pick up but this is the one I already posted
new has not been
is the following when you have the
some specific classes of
applications such as games
they have resources within them that are
specific to a certain certain
hardware features for example
one of the examples I always use is
shape and texture compressed in the
gospel notes how specific it is
in the form of textures included in
pdl
so in this case you have certain devices
in those a format and texture and others
that the use
the ep format to the video card in the
truth differences through the law all
different people
so in these cases sometimes it's worth it
apply separately because otherwise
You'll have to put all the
textures for some device and all
the sectors to other positives within
of the same score only that the children
deaf on some little saved
hundreds of megabytes
especially about 3g super fast for
download
that is when the son of musicians
even home exists for a scenario and last
if that is the scenario if you really
Can not make a small one for
work because you're going to
if you fall into those cases where you
have to do very specific things
for specific cases
then yes I use multiple apk if it can be
a good idea but as soon as
routinely this should not be
your first solution does not even sign on
second solution
when you when you make a 50 51
number 52 years later 52 solutions that
did not work and in the 53rd
accept you think make multiple
but it is a stay of the 53rd
Thinking about this incompatibility jean
Souza with your Brazil with the state here.
he said the following part with
possibility exists an easy way
use mep saw fragment by what
I researched a size but changed
online support and that's right
then to that question enough
frequency is just to summarize the
problem with that
is when you use a goal and saw it has
to take from one in category to
province is trying to put that
fragments our great value in the
then there is a problem and in the
dance and when you are using the
pious shopping a flagrant
the solution then you will see that this
conflict
so there is no official way of
laws that is not how you download or
our support for it will not get out of the
box working though has a good
she is open source news
so you can make a
change in her if a rap is made in her
which is a well-known echo in the
true if you look for this I think
I do not know that the return must have I think
way to do this is that it is a
way of you
Are you changing it from the father to the father of each
class in a way that you can do
this is not it
but it is so answering the question has a
Easy way I think this is easy and
is not paper from all quarters
example they already lose it's nothing you go
will spend half of your day and having
problem with that now ask yourself why
have the official way of doing this using
the way she has it is in the
moment is not good but it is a movie that is
Frequently we're looking at this.
Our happy port is one of the other
areas that are very important for the
people then the crisis is always
improving it a lot we are
working now for example on how to
make this port happy and want to function
with edson barboza power to use action
boats through the superliga in
previous versions
That's what we announced in Brazil and the
We've been working on this a lot.
since then we still do not have a
prediction of when this will launch in
because it is a very complicated thing and the
people want to do it right it's no use
we throw a frightful thing
playing different version the luck that I
I think you make a version just goes
It might take a little longer
In this issue, we do not have a
prediction repeats tomorrow our colleague
It's going to launch, we're actually maybe
it may take you where you do not know where
He's and he's at his desk flipping.
now he knows we do not know anything but it's in
general is that engineering calendar
that you all know exists
released exists soon there never ever
certainly of his three administrations
certainly action bar in porto alegre
It's going to be soon It's not even launched nor ever
certainly soon to the regal question
Is there a moment you have any more connection to?
person then the flag slipper has more
a question we do not have a question to
question where I'm from January
let's act the fashion sound and beauty beauty
android the company recently is that
was issued a version of the express that is
the fucking business that we use
been here right now and was released for
and of course what a software event is like
was asked why he did not have a
android version
only that the ninth case gives the boy what
made the system
he explained as soon as Google did not
do not know that some things in
that in my view, how I always participate
I did not think I did much of these lectures.
right direction
I just wanted to know about you how
works like this with the company android is
more so it does not support what the
sir putting so he expresses a
owner application that developed
a customer like this option that does not
they are entitled to question then the express
it's like you're an e-mail server
which is used for so state only
17 in the case of work for the government and
It's used for everything everything has to do.
with government is to use the express as and
among them
You understood that we have now released a version
for i is the one there, for example i
I work as a neighborhood but I
interested in learning I would like to
who knows the opportunity to
development for android
so I think that's the comment
the developer was that he did not
decided to ban because there is no support
of the egg is that the retreat is not because the
next is when he says there is no
support he may be meaning
several things certainly for example not
there is a line that does not exist 10 800 that
You pick up the phone and call soon or
having problem with this class other than
Understand that it was naomi, it does not exist
this in fact we do not have support in this
level because we believe the following
we want our platform to be
good enough you do not need to talk
with someone specifically for why
is giving trouble in Lebanon and one of the
our outbreaks
it means here with android or any
another thing is scalability ie we
we want to take courses and work from a
So that we help many people
at the same time then for us the
help a person individually wants to
saying it's worth less than if I can
a way day of god in the community
as a whole then for example up to
because if you have a common problem with
many people see having to solve a
only to ensure that they have a
solid platform
I think what we have every time
plus our support that the entity
another way the poles of the through
example of rebels such as this
what we give is in relation to improving
more and more our documentation then
if you go it still reveals to the taker
is to heat the documentation
android is very very full remember
that even before entering the goal I
know program very well android because
the complete documentation there means
You exist, you need very very little.
more than what's really there
then love and so only one has
The issue of support is also
developed in trips both the hotel
recently on google here completed a
month yesterday but so I was developing
android there since 2007 when the sdk came out
and I learned in this kind of thing the site but
is the point is this is the question of what the
support our strong is subjective medium is
because so if you think it's a
server and is of the state and that
you must have a protocol if you do not follow the
standard protocol of medium is it could
to use the normal normal classes android
of access to the soccket falls in hypothesis
could include lower access and
only this via socket sent from brother-in-law
documentation and could make the customer
create so much that there are customers
email to many in google places
can download
so now if he expects a kind of
specific support is up to the bruno is
coming here to stay in 20 states
united and I'm going to stay officially
in Brazil as a channel
We've been doing some kind of support
as far as possible and blush cool faces
we respond that the technical cells
to see fire is not also the community
Android in Brazil is very strong, okay?
I'll quote a personal case later.
The staff at the 800 forgive me but she never
if you stay even that's what I founded
the list you have a list called
android brazil should or not is official
google but there are over 1300
developers there like exchanging more
two messages per month
outside this has several blogs in several
sites also that does not suffer in this galera
gets engaged in pretty much like this
do not support the scale
of age gives the team support is a
face to face there but personal as a
all for its free software gives a lot
good luck too
so it is and so we left
open to students if for example the person
have some because of some difficulty
specific is that we have this channel
from google apps to chat with
people and participate in senegal x knows the
people are trying to
maximum of 30 of supportcomm
Brazilian families will certainly
certainly is a very important thing
that the grandson mentioned is the century I
I'm blowing who does not know is
Talked this is maybe the point with it
and it's not a google tool ok
No, it's not a google platform anymore.
I'm going to be part of our android team
is engaged in this platform to
answer questions just from
specific technical questions on the
example how does this work as
that works because that does not work
like this
so I want to be with her, she's a
of our main support channels
So it is the rebels I do not think
is with the sun is one of our channels
main health
recommends that this time I want
if any player has any one
question is more complicated about
android it's worth you to post one
century the focus because not only what
say not only google support
how it sells from the android community as
strong right then trade is talking
I also think that the user community
and android developers is a force
gigantic no force means that
certainly the agent must say that
prestige with certainty then what the
people want like like google is not like the
android is not that the people who see you
people do not want to just come back for a stone
1992 only we who know the android do not
I think it's this
we do not want to be the evangelists
forever android everyone looks
We want what we want.
community members criticize the
community and the healthy ecosystem
What many experts are there?
out of the goal and this is fundamental to
have a platform with critical mass
constant of defining and governing
This is not the name of your
consulate
obviously someone who already developed a
the e-mail client can question the
that this person has
so I do not think he does.
have the support that he expected
google today
that was a specific right and so
we can not have been himself
had scales imagined Brazil is a country
of continental size
before it was just bruno now it's just me
I think we have to meet the
people the best way you can
but it is, and another is reiterating that
that specific person is the
developed something in contact
by the tel in the post put in doubt in
sense person to participate in the rescue with
We think this is interesting.
join in too
beauty has a thing right because everything
that saying everything we do not do is a
market opportunity still imagines
for example ooo which is cooler than
android is right on the us nodes
we want to be the owner of android do not want
everybody see the goal with us
we are the owners of android we want
to do everything is nothing prevents for example from
someone in brazil in any country
I counted on the android consulting that gives
just that 10 801 droid support that
we do not give
so there is a market opportunity
besides opening a company and many
minimum functions in Régis
The world does this by citing two
but they make money from the support
no it's not the linval torvalds wallet that
Did you have the phone to support?
a good symptom of a shame the last
bruno idea as a general idea and
very acceptable specific tool
is this possibility an idea I
I thought it would be interesting to
possibility exists there actually is
mathematically speaking there is a
an infinite and determined set of
keys you tighten fra you make the
interface become a reality that is
write her code and then post
But that's exactly the question.
It was very interesting because of that, right?
because if there is no such
idea is today
it means if you are not satisfied
with this idea can be an excellent
opportunity for you to create this is
the etf it is also public the eclipse is
think yes then you can inclusive
catch the eclipse that many companies
make it take the eclipse itself and
the pains that you think an idea
new né ô ô ô lucas dedé for example
hypothesis may have struggles with the idea
based on android we do not want
reduce or new zealand with the new year
will start in 2009 the company
remembers that pt does not do anything magical nor
movie team do nothing magic
because they call themselves the tools of
android is not android sdk
depends on the team is and only a notion to the
sometimes it is wrong that people have
teams from the 2nd android sequel
not true but it ends android is a
toolkit, eclipse is one of the
another thing and has a plugin detection of
eclipse that makes the bridge then
with the source sensor and then
command line for example only
like people like the face I think it's
a beautiful one is the terminal
so the guy goes there at the terminal
point bar to see something we found
that compile but you do not have
no restriction if you make another
idea now think the hotel is a sub
ask who I am there is interest
google to interface
android specific
It means at the moment we are
quite happy with what we have
now in the team but to have né
and you are very happy with the
system as a whole or is it has
people in eclipse have people not
understand smart try people
using for example the motor must have
people using the oracle you have
a series of 10 there that they exist
errors and which is better or not
in that religious discussion about cordel
It's better, but what we want
just that this dynamic has this
and you have the freedom to do it
that you want to use the idea is that you
want to
If you're stuck there's nothing that we
People say no, that's the way
sure they do not think the android is you
you can choose the screen size o
phone manufacturer you can
to choose the lady's version is
school you want to use the
that fits best in this situation but
we at least currently do not
has no meaning but has no
none is any plan to have an idea
own dodo
at least not at the moment I had
Question that is interesting is she
ask uncle s
Good to gay tst I imagine that this
question is how you get to use the
android sdk
then this just means to a
of interesting things of android is
that the documentation is very complete then
if you go to candle to photograph
dot com and you want to download apple if
You or you must be trying.
to rescue the story then I think
complete documentation to begin
develop from scratch
I remember when I started from scratch
go to android did not have difficulty
None like that is just you and the documentation
it was much more rustic than it is
Not today
nowadays, for example, we have a
something I did not have at the time I started
What are those classes, freire?
coast sit if you go in there
model possesses now is so strange
back lessons
step-by-step lessons
how to perform some tasks on android
such as well-focused topics
for example to create victims
create and load it
enough then there's a class to
this has those sentences and 3g is
this is important not only topics
courses, but also classes and classes
shooting lessons and they have
Fragment classes then have since
then you have never developed the
android is if you are interested
all you need to have one
reasonable knowledge of java in the
language that another Joshua obviously
is outside the scope of our
explained that it is a class
which is a reference
there are several but I have up to
resources but if you already have a certain
familiarity with java is very easy
you embark android through our
documentation is certainly beyond the
I have a question for you to do that.
topic of a question
the second is you lead to the classic
the excuse is you're used so had
I do not know if it's the google tool
I think it was that I wanted to app
inventor of mit
now it's the mit that takes care of him so the
Google gave up applying
so the film that had some partnership
with something like this in the oec event goes
For those who do not know, he's making it up.
is a way for you to create a
middle android app to protest
a coffin android fast way to
everyone can create it what
happened to him was that the people
decided to shift our focus to other
priorities because the event is legal
for you to make your first prototype
android right né
but that's not a way for you
create a robust and robust
ready for programming is more
is a tool that prioritizes the
ease of prototyping on the
quality of the software then either
say the we've moved a little focus on the
decided to focus our more is to stay
even to ensure that your
players had the best
tools to make gmail app
of production does not mean that the
event was poor does not mean that the
people decided to change the focus a little
is only fahel the fact that he is the
if it is to allow Haiti to
You can continue with it.
so we do not have anything against pepper
but it was only a change of focus that they
will do to prioritize precisely the
that our audience, who are the
winners
the audience I wanted to enjoy
This hook, that's personal, I'm
Starting a job in Brazil today.
included only in as as member of the
blog in which develops with the code
brings google is the blogspot.com dot
so from next week and I
I'll start doing some
more blog entries starts to
to post some things is we have some
events coming around and energy from
Paulo is going to be a party day because it's
an event that is not just people like the
to support these events including myself
I liked it when I had the renato lage that
is another problem on crohn's part
I'll go over more details later.
these events is already beginning a
I work in Brazil with communities of
jesus for those who are not as a model
groups or the old generals
so if you there in the society of
interest in creating a group
amy searches after retreating through google
plus and I'll post some things then
so I believe that the next months
it will be very interesting that part
community will intensify with
And he wants to spread some
google programs in brazil where
to disclose soon
so it's just to give you an input
to access the blog has no entry there
places in the USSR to become operational
blog revenue that still if still
for six years ending up more than
November there are some news to us
will share with you through there
and of course neither during the
calendar and the skalegas you see
Quite cool, there's the thing.
interesting but it's a live question
But we close this up, guys.
dedicated to moderator products to do
a question
Good, thanks.
It was very nice talking to you and me.
look to send the ball came to him in the
wave of léo that was in Brazil mode
You're here to post the link and it's going to
send while the staff continues
trying to think that before he was in a
video recorded now on youtube because
No one posted the link there.
who knows her well because of the
subject with no one connected to us going
Back, thank you very much for doing this.
first drama there and here at headquarters
of google in mountain view in brazil
luckily I got out and then when
higher but the event is
talking to you is the future
Thank you good evening, staff west west.